joe biden has solved the racial
achievement gap
this took a long time you know some
people blamed this system
some people blamed cultural differences
but joe
has finally identified the real problem
black people just can't get accountants
the data shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
that's it they're great entrepreneurs
they just they
just don't have accountants you know
they're such good entrepreneurs that
they don't know how to call up
h r block but they have good ideas you
know that's what's really important
in business is have no one has any ideas
it's
ideas at a buck 50 i'll get you a cup of
coffee if only it were that easy
as joe biden says the left has more
dramatic plans for cultural revolution
than that
government diversity mandates a racial
caste system
and even gender nullification surgery to
make people look like ken dolls
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from kevin beach
who says why does a mother or a father
only get one day to celebrate their
contribution to society and be
celebrated
the lgbtq pride gets a month
shorten that up a bit please no it's
more than a month it's two months
it's there's june which is pride month
and there's i believe it's october
is lgbt history month so a full
sixth of the year is now dedicated to
sort of unusual sexual desires but yeah
one day for mom
one day for dad and i guess you have one
month for
for black history but only some black
history right it's not
not all sorts it's not uh thomas soul
month okay it's not clarence thomas
month
then there's another month for women's
history it's the liturgical calendar
is very very full in liberalism it's
very very crazy
makes one want to just run away and if
you wanted to get away
you need some some great shoes on your
feet i would recommend
all birds a curious spirit and deep
appreciation for nature
is the very core of all birds started
with co-founder tim brown wondering why
sustainable merino wool
was not more widely used for its
remarkable qualities i love mourinho
wool
tim teamed up with engineer and
renewables expert joey
to create their first groundbreaking
shoe the wool runner today
they lead the industry in crafting
quality footwear and apparel with
natural materials
and finding more sustainable ways to
operate the tree runners are breathable
they're machine washable they're made
with responsibly sourced eucalyptus tree
fiber
simple and versatile design makes the
tree runner a perfect go-to shoe for
any outfit packaging made from 90
recycled cardboard
that's a shoebox shopping bag and mailer
all
in one all birds has been dedicated to
reducing environmental impact since day
one
from operations to production they treat
the planet like a key stakeholder in
the company really great stuff you know
we like to conserve things we like
beautiful nature we like to be around
this lovely earth
and we like to look good doing it this
spring keep things light and breezy with
the all birds tree runner
discovery your perfect fair at
allbirds.com that's a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com some conservatives are making
the argument because of joe biden's
stupid comments that he is a racist
and i guess in a way he is but they're
making the argument not that he's
uh just a racist generally but that he's
a white supremacist
because he's made these comments about
black people he said that you know
barack obama's the first clean
articulate black man
in american politics or something to
that effect that was a bit offensive
he said that uh poor kids are just as
talented as white kids that was a bit
offensive and now he said that black
entrepreneurs can't succeed because they
don't know how to call
h r block but but i i don't
i don't think he's a white supremacist i
think this argument of you know
democrats are the real white
supremacists i think that's
kind of silly i think it's a bit of a
coping mechanism
i don't think that republicans or
conservatives are racist i mean i
frankly i don't even know what that word
means anymore
it's been so watered down to me nothing
but i don't think conservatives or
republicans hold any particular
racial animosity at all i don't think
they think about race very much
whatsoever and i
say this with some authority being a
conservative republican myself
and it certainly is the case that
democrats and leftists do think about
race a lot
but they're not white supremacists i
just think that that's a
silly statement to make they are
advancing a racial caste system
but they want it to disadvantage whites
and they want it to give they want to
give advan
just like affirmative action give
advantages to certain groups like black
people and hispanics
and disadvantage other groups like white
people and asians that is what they're
calling for and and
any any way to twist that i think is
just a way to buy into the premise that
the only evil in the entire world is
anti-black racism
that's very bad there are other bad
things too
joe biden was pretty clear about this
the other day he came out
and he said that the single greatest
threat today in america is
is what would you say it's kovid maybe
no would you say that it's
the the lockdowns you know would you say
it's depression now would you say it's
drugs no would you say it's
violence in the streets from people like
blm and antifa no you know what it is
white supremacy according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal
threat to the homeland today not isis
not al-qaeda white supremacists
so that's just preposterous right i mean
i guess the single greatest threat is
heart disease
followed by what followed by various
other ailments and then if we're talking
about violence in the streets it's not
it's not from white supremacists okay
they're just there isn't a whole lot of
that
this statement doesn't even hold up if
you only look at race crimes
or rather if you only look at hate
crimes which have a racial component
very often when you look at hate crime
statistics and you look at
white perpetrators and black
perpetrators you find out that black
people are far more likely to commit
hate crimes than white people are i'm
sure there are many reasons for this and
one could discuss all of it i'm not
making any claim about what the reasons
are but i'm just saying if you believe
that white supremacy is the greatest
threat
that isn't even true when you're looking
at hate crimes
hate crimes a kind of silly category
because i guess it's the opposite of a
love crime
aren't too many love crimes as far as i
can tell we are now living in a system
that is upholding and advancing a new
sort of racial cast breaking out of the
colorblind society
that everyone had been striving to
create for a long time there's now a
racial caste system
and white people are considered to be
the sort of embodiment
of evil in this system the single
greatest threat to the country
there are different standards here when
you're looking at how to punish crime
depending on ideology and specifically
on racial politics greatest example of
this
january 6th you know january what
happened on january 6th
the worst most dangerous
insurrection coup d'etat
in the or it was a guy with horns
dancing on a desk in the capitol
or it was a bunch of people
stealing nancy pelosi's lectern i'm not
excusing this it's not a good thing to
do
but it's not the storming of the
bastille it's not it's not
the worst insurrection in american
history it's not even the worst
insurrection
in the year leading up to january 6th in
the year leading up to january 6th you
had blm
burning down the country you had antifa
burning down the country
and you had a guy in horns dancing on
pelosi's desk
both bad but bad to different degrees
and yet
the blm people basically get off the
hook the antifa people basically get off
the hook
and the guy in the horns oh man they're
going to throw the book at him right now
very very high level prosecutors
prosecutors who work on homicide
prosecutors who work on terrorism
are being brought in to try the capitol
hill rioters
for trespassing
basically just for trespassing maybe the
theft of
taking nancy pelosi's lectern initially
we were told in the newspapers that
these rioters had killed police officers
that's not true even the left left-wing
newspapers admit that now
so you're going to have the the toughest
highest level prosecutors in the country
federal prosecutors
brought in to try trespassing what about
what about the blm people who trespassed
what about the antifa people who that
doesn't matter that's fine there's a
different standard there
because of different political
ideologies and because of racial
politics what about that there's some
good news on this front
which is that the gop was
debating whether or not to form a
january 6th commission
this was going to be a commission set up
by the
u.s senate and the u.s house of
representatives akin to the 911
commission
because january 6th was just like
september 11
and there were a number of squish
republicans who were going to go along
with this mitt romney and those sorts of
types
thankfully though the january 6th
commission failed
and we had a feeling this would fail
because cocaine mitch mcconnell said a
couple of weeks ago
i've decided we're not going to do this
oh say hello to my little friend and so
so you
you didn't have to worry about it the
reason it failed though is not because
they couldn't muster a majority
in the senate the reason is because of a
filibuster
right you know there's a higher
threshold because of the filibuster
and the democrats have not nuked the
filibuster yet
so there will be no january 6th
commission if you don't
get that january 6th was not the same
thing as september 11th
you're not on our side i don't know how
else you are
if you believe that january 6th was like
9 11
i'm not saying you've got to approve of
january 6th i don't i don't know anyone
who really does
but if you if you don't realize that
it's different than 9 11
you're not a conservative you shouldn't
be lumped in with conservatives
if you think that january 6 was worse
than the blm riots i don't think
you're really a conservative now some
people
get this some people don't but some
people do we yesterday on the show
we played that that speech by paul ryan
over the weekend
or paul ryan former speaker of the house
representative i guess now of the sort
of
economics-only moderate wing of the
republican party
and he just doesn't seem to know what
time it is
he said we need to focus only on
economics basically and not at all on
culture
there's another republican leader in
this country who recognizes
the exact opposite is true that man you
can probably guess his name
florida governor ron desantis some of
these battles of what the left is doing
and woke-ism
you know it's effectively cultural
marxism and so
you can have theoretically a successful
um economy but if the underpinnings of
the culture
are just being torn apart i don't think
that that's a society that's going to be
very uh very successful over the long
term
bingo baby he's said a lot of words here
that you're not allowed to say notably
cultural marxism
which is just another term it's a
problematic term because people use it
to mean different things but what he's
referring to is a very real phenomenon
there were
people in the marxist tradition marxist
philosophers who
recognized that marx failed because he
viewed man as fundamentally economic and
material
rather than cultural and so they applied
marx's ideas to culture
uh this was done through people like
antonio gramsci this was done through
the frankfurt school this weirdest ugly
head again and
in the new left and it gave us political
correctness which i described at length
in my upcoming book speech list
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
and available for a signed first edition
copy of premiere collectibles
ron desantis has some some real guts
here to even say that phrase because if
you go on wikipedia in the past few
years
cultural marxism a very well-known
intellectual movement
has now been called an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory
conspiracy i don't know how it's a
conspiracy theory at all because there
are many
marxist writers who describe themselves
as
cultural figures but i don't know how
it's anti-semitic either because the
most prominent one of them was an
italian guy not a jew
never mind they don't really care when
they're trying to censor people
ron desantis calls it out he says yeah
it's good to have tax cuts it's good to
have regulatory reform but if you lose
the whole culture none of that's going
to matter this is the exact
point we were making on the show
yesterday this guy
knows what time it is if you got a
future the gop is either going to go in
the paul ryan direction
or the ron desantis direction the only
way we're going to
we're going to stick around is if we go
in the ron desantis direction now put it
in the senate
is the gop going to go in the mitt
romney direction is it going to go in
the ted cruz direction
if it goes in the romney direction we're
not going anywhere if it goes in the
cruise direction
or the hawley direction or any of the
conservatives
you're going to be going in the right
place when you want to go to the right
place to get auto parts by the way you
should check out
rockauto rockauto.com is so much easier
than walking into a store
and someone demanding quick answers to
things such as hey michael
is your honda a gt7 or a qx3
it's like i don't know man it's gray is
that does that give you an answer no
they don't know but then
you figure it out they go into the back
they don't have the part they never have
the part they go online probably to
rockota.com they charge you twice as
much
that seems like a big waste of time and
a waste of money when you could go to
rockauto.com
a family company always has reliably low
prices
they don't change their prices every
single day based on a bunch of gimmicks
the catalog is so simple and easy to
navigate
even i can do it and they've got the
same prices for pros such as myself
and do-it-yourselfers such as you so
head on over to rockauto.com
you can quickly check out all the parts
for your car or truck that you want
today that's rockauto.com and then write
nullscannerwles in there how did you
hear about usbox
so they know that we sent you so
ron desantis totally knows what time it
is on the culture
he gets that tax cuts and regulatory
reform
are worth approximately nothing
if we lose our national identity if we
lose
our culture if we lose our traditional
american way of life
desantis is not just speaking pie in the
sky
in abstractions desantis is putting this
into action
he just signed a bill banning
uh dudes from playing in women's sports
now the way this is being reported
this according to wfla quote
breaking on the first day of pride month
ron desantis signs bill banning
transgender females from girls and
women's sports oh man that sounds bad
doesn't it
that headline doesn't that really
doesn't sound good but then i thought
okay let me
let me translate that that line from
wokist into english let's let's and so
the translation would be on the first
day of pride month scratch that
on the first day of june governor ron
desantis signs bill banning transgender
female what is oh that's a man
governor ron desantis signs a bill
banning men from girls and women's
sports all right
that makes perfect sense that what that
shouldn't even be a news story
why is it news that the i guess the news
story is that the governor had to sign a
bill
to ban men from women's sports because
it should be common
sense but the common sense ain't that
common anymore
now this was a pretty courageous move
here
you know other governors around the
country have balked at this sort of
thing
christy gnome came under a lot of fire
for this christine
good governor she's done a lot of good
things in the past year
but she she whiffed it she kind of blew
it on the issue of transgender sports
because she signed a bill
that would keep men out of the girls
locker room
for k-12 but she or she was willing to
sign that bill but she wouldn't
go all the way she wouldn't sign it
because
she didn't want to exclude men from
women's sports at the collegiate level
and the defenders of governor gnome's
decision said look it's impossible the
ncaa they were threatening to pull
events out of the state and she was
afraid it wouldn't hold up and
there was too much pressure and okay
well
that's too bad it's too bad when our
leaders cave
under that sort of pressure ron desantis
not so much
you can't be cowed by these
organizations or particularly by woke
corporations
from doing the right thing and so my
view was throughout this whole time we
have to protect our girls
it is discriminatory to force them to
compete
against biological males and so if the
price of
having a tournament is that i have to
deny equal opportunity
to hundreds of thousands of young girls
and women athletes throughout florida
i am much more willing to stand with the
girls
and to hell with these events what i
think we've shown not just with this but
we did a strong election integrity bill
in florida actually stronger than
georgia
and we just made it clear we're standing
with our folks
we're going to do the right thing uh and
so if corporations want to come in and
try to bully us around they are going to
go nowhere
it's going to be like hitting their head
against a brick wall the result
has been we've had very little uh to do
with that elections bill and i don't
think we're going to have very much to
do at this point here
because we leaned into it and we stood
strong
to hell with those events if the cost of
those events
is now what rhonda sanders is saying is
if the cost of those events is
denying opportunity to women and girls
than to help with those events okay a
perfectly fine reason
but frankly i don't really think this is
about women's sports
i think this is about reality
at the broader level if the cost of
those events if the cost of
corporate money is that we need to deny
reality
and live in lies and propagate lies and
and conduct our society in delusion
to hell with those corporations i don't
we don't need to do that
it's not worth it the price is too high
so we're all duking it out now over the
female sports thing
but it's it's about so so much more than
that
and desantis understands this
how many politicians in the country
understand this sort of thing
not very many not very many realize that
you've got to lean in
on the cultural issues and the ones who
do by the way
are absolutely castigated by everyone
else in their party people i'm thinking
of are
guys like desantis guys like cruz
guys like i suppose hawley he's persona
non grata now
and some other other politicians as well
this is the right answer wokism is
purely
destructive okay it is
this is the thesis of my upcoming book
speechless controlling where it's
controlling mine's available now for
pre-order
it's purely destructive it seeks to
destroy
the old standards it will not allow
there to be women's sports it will not
allow there to be a women's bathroom it
will not allow there to be
a sexual difference at all ultimately it
will not even acknowledge
sex and this this has come out in the
creepiest news story
i have seen since yesterday there were a
lot of creepy news stories yesterday
and somehow there's another one today
gender nullification have you heard
about this gender
nullification surgery
so that you've got this broad woke
ideology that is based they say it's
about redefining and expanding and
inclusion and diversity but we know that
it's not when you
when you redefine marriage to take away
the essence of marriage
you don't expand it you don't make it
more inclusive you just destroy it and
now you've just you've got you've taken
one institution off the table
which the left has been after for a
hundred years and which blm is still
honest about right they say they want to
destroy
the western prescribed nuclear family
when you
take away the difference between men and
women it's not that you're expanding
the genders right you know to the 150
genders that they pretend that there are
you're just destroying sex you're
destroying gender and one group of
surgeons
is admitting this there is
a new surgery being performed by the
align
surgical associates based in san
francisco i know you're going to be
shocked to hear that
to nullify sex quote nullification
creates a relatively continuous and
mostly
unbroken transition from the abdomen
down to the genital
area enabling gender non-conforming
patients
to enjoy a body that looks closer on the
outside
to the way they feel on the inside
so it turns you into a ken doll
or a barbie doll you know where your
pelvis is just completely flat
it just not only mutilates your genitals
to look
different than they currently look it
just tries to erase them
entirely and this is in the name of
health
if i walked into a doctor's office today
and i said you know i feel as though i
only have one arm
they say well michael you manifestly
have two arms i say i know
that you're saying that but that's very
hurtful to me because i identify as
someone with one arm
and even if physically even if by an
accident of birth
i was i was assigned two arms at birth i
know that deep down
in my true self i'm a one-armed man
so i need you to perform a surgery and
cut off my arm
to make me feel on the outside more like
i feel on the inside
i would at least today i would be
committed to a mental institution for
saying that
because that is crazy talk you can't no
doctor today
as far as i know would perform that
surgery
that would violate the hippocratic oath
doctors are
supposed to at first at least do no harm
then they're trying to help you
when you mutilate perfectly functioning
organs you are harming people
however if i go in and instead of saying
hey doctor i want you to cut my arm off
if i said hey i want you to cut off a
far more sensitive part
many many doctors in the country would
do this they would
they would mutilate me if i asked them
to and
in some cases they would encourage me to
do that because of kooky
cultish theories about sex and gender
this i i think this sort of surgery
underscores a point that conservatives
have not wanted to accept for a long
time but
increasingly we are we have to say
no to certain things we should not allow
that to happen we should use
big government and regulations to stop
private citizens and private businesses
like doctor's offices
from doing that it's not enough to say
hey if you want to chop off your
organs and your limbs that's fine just
don't make me pay for it no it's not
fine it's wrong it's actually wrong it's
evil it's unjust you shouldn't do it
it's not compassionate to the people who
are very confused who want this done
it's not good for society it's contrary
to the practice of medicine
it's contrary to justice and truth and
goodness and beauty and the american way
don't do it you have to you have to be
comfortable banning things
if you want to preserve freedom you need
to say no
to licentiousness if you want to
preserve free speech you have to say no
you have to censor speech that
undermines free speech
this is apparently a controversy this
wouldn't have been a controversial
thesis
even 50 years ago this is apparently a
controversial thesis today
and one that i advance in my upcoming
book speechless controlling controlling
minds available now for pre-order it's a
great book to read by the way
while you are sort of sitting out
relaxing trying to
bring together all of the craziness of
this world trying to focus
you know ben is going to be talking
about
one of our favorite villains in the
world today
dr anthony fouchy
you sheep you dumb mask wearing sheep
uh go check that out also be sure to
check out ben's new book the
authoritarian moment which is available
now for pre-order
at amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller
i really love this title because i'm
going to steal it to be my campaign
slogan when i'm running
next time it'll be knowles 2028 the
authoritarian moment go check that out
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
not to harp too much on the creepy
gender nullification surgery
but these sickos at the alliance
surgical associates the san francisco
doctors group that's that's turning
humans into kendall's
they perform other surgeries too they'll
they'll
perform surgeries where they will you
know if you're a woman you go in
where they will sort of construct an
organ that looks
like a like a phallus but they'll keep
your
your actual genitals there too so you
you'll just be
you'll look more like a hermaphrodite
and they'll do the same thing for men
this is not this is not the purpose of
medicine
the purpose of medicine is to take
things that are not functioning and make
them function
appropriately or to make them function
better
if your kidneys aren't working well then
they're going to have some interventions
put you on dialysis make your
kidneys function a little bit better if
your eyes aren't functioning very well
you can't really see
they're going to work on your eyes and
they're going to make you see a little
bit better
this presumes that things have a purpose
and that your body parts have a purpose
but we deny that now in our culture we
deny that our body parts have any
purpose we deny
purpose entirely or the technical term t
loss
and so because we deny that things get a
little kooky
where you say well anything can be or do
any other thing
and now the purpose of medicine has
transformed from fixing things and
making them do what they're supposed to
do
pursuing justice to
fantasy to creating fantasies and
turning people into all sorts of things
that they are not and that they they
really ought not to be
now this is all done in the name of
compassion and in the name of pride it's
very prideful
it's very prideful to say that we can
recreate the world according to our own
fancies and that we have the right to do
that and that we ought to do that
and that the world will be much better
not
according to nature and pursuing justice
but according to our own fantasies and
our own basis desires
the the pride issue is so much bigger
than sex
everyone wants to make it just about the
gays you know or just a vet that
now i guess including transgender
whatever it's about so much more than
that it's about a leftist
political program to transform
all of reality that the idea that we can
redefine reality by redefining words
a thesis advance my upcoming book
speechless controlling writes
intelligence might available now for
pre-order
it's what whitaker chambers said is the
the second oldest
ideology in the world that began in the
garden of eden when the serpent told ev
shall be his gods
but that's what this is about that's
what constructing someone's
body to look like something that they
never were
is about and we're advancing this
ideology around the world the u.s
embassy at the holy see
at the vatican is flying a pride flag
for pride month now
it's a little bit offensive you see
because the catholic church
uh it has a different view of sex than
the pride view of sex
and the vatican you know the holy see
is an independent country and they've
invited us to have an embassy there
and we are now foisting the or sort of
radical sexual views
on the vatican we would not be doing
this
in the places like saudi arabia we would
not be doing this in the middle east
i i don't think if you if you took a
survey of middle eastern
arab state embassies right now i don't
think you'd find all that many pride
flags okay but you will find them poking
an eye
poking the eye of the catholic church
because they know
that the catholic church is not going to
do anything and they know that some of
the arab states will riot and try to
kill them
that's what it's about right and because
the problem
that the american left has is not with
the arab states they don't have the
problem with islam
they're not advancing any particularly
positive vision they're just trying to
tear down western civilization itself
they're trying to nullify it they're
trying to abolish it
and the catholic church is the
representative institution of the
civilization
because it built the civilization and it
just won't go away
they keep trying to destroy they've been
trying to destroy it for hundreds and
hundreds of years now and
it just won't go away one evidence by
the way of its divine institution
a hillary bellow made this point he said
look i'm i'm required as a matter of my
faith to believe that the church is
divinely inspired but for those of you
who are non-believers
one piece of evidence for its its divine
institution
is that any other organization conducted
with such navish imbecility
would not have lasted a fortnight
despite all the scandals despite all of
the
sometimes outright idiotic uh
governance of the church from from some
of its leaders
the church endures and and the united
states seems a little upset about that
this is i think more evidence of a point
i made on the show yesterday
that the reason that the left is
rallying around the pride flag or the
blm flag right now as opposed to
the american flag where they protest the
american flag but they put the pride
flag up everywhere
is because the pride flag is a symbol of
liberal imperialism
the american flag is still a symbol of
the american nation the pride flag and
the blm flag for that matter are symbols
of
liberal empire this idea of a sort of
universal
secularism that is not limited to one
nation with borders
but it's it's not bounded at all it
actually should apply to every
nation on the face of the earth
including and especially the catholic
church
and i think that's that's the divide
between say the nationalist and the
globalist right this was the the
dichotomy that trump
showed us in 2016. the people who
support the american nation
wave the american flag the people who
want to get rid of our american borders
and support global liberal empire ironic
they say they're anti-colonial but
they're actually the most imperialist
people in the world
they wave the rainbow flag and they wave
the blm flag now there are some problems
within the catholic church as well as
you as you may have heard
but i think a lot of them are
disingenuous you know people who
are defending the the pride flag at the
vatican right now
they're saying well look it's how dare
the catholic church raise a problem
about this the catholic church
has scandals where the priests have
molested
little boys that's true that's true
there have been those scandals
there have been priests who have abused
children very terrible horrible like the
basically the worst thing you can
imagine you think it's only the catholic
church that has done that because i
i don't think it is when you look at
surveys on this
issue the catholic church is no more
likely to do these things
than other religious groups but moreover
catholic priests are significantly less
likely to have abused
children than public school teachers
the the rate of abuse so it by the way
the abu it's not so the abuse is really
ongoing
certainly not in anywhere to the degree
that it was the abuse came
after the tumult of the 1960s at more
broadly you know
the craziness the sexual revolution
across the broader culture and vatican
ii the second vatican council which
really
created an upheaval in the church the
the sexual abuse peaked during the 1970s
and 80s and it dropped off precipitously
after that
and the rate of abuse including at the
height
is has been estimated to be about four
percent
insanely high and it's hard to get good
numbers on this but the estimate is
about four percent
this has obviously been investigated
quite a lot the rate of sexual abuse
among public school teachers five to
seven percent
so yes it's very important to fix all
these problems but i i don't want to
hear it you there's a double standard
that's being pushed
and i i don't want to hear that the
catholic priests are uniquely
uh guilty here when the the catholic
priests
are are attacked because they're
representatives of the of the catholic
church
the public school teachers are
representatives of the secular
progressive state
and they abuse children at a far greater
rate so
if we're going to talk about the issue
let's bring out all of the facts
now there has been an infiltration
within the catholic church there's no
question about that
there is a famous heretical priest i
don't know i don't know how else to put
it i want to i want to be as respectful
as i can but
that is as polite away as i can put it
this heretical priest father james
martin
who is a big advocate often implicitly
but sometimes he verges on the explicit
of
redefining marriage within the faith to
take away sexual difference something
that is impossible you actually can't do
it
but he has suggested that we ought to
and uh so father martin tweeted out
quote
uh mr and mrs boris johnson this is the
thrice married british prime minister
we're married within the rules of the
catholic church and i wish them well
i also wish that the very same mercy and
compassion that was offered to them
recognizing their complex lives could
also be extended
to same-sex couples who are life-long
catholics okay
he's saying that because boris johnson
has been married multiple times and
there were certain dispensations and
things given
that's evidence that we need to redefine
marriage to take away sexual difference
which is at the essence of marriage the
left always seems to do this
they always seem to say that if there is
any
slight imperfection any slight hypocrisy
within the tradition that means we
should
not fix the people who are
and the institutions and the traditions
that are
you know opposing that and bring
everybody
more into compliance with the objective
order but that we should get rid of all
those traditions
entirely we should deny that traditional
order entirely
right so if boris johnson is thrice
married
that's not an argument for making it
harder to get divorced
that's taken as an argument to abolish
marriage well why can't we just toughen
things up a little bit
i think in part this is because
conservatives have been unwilling
to say no we have what for the past
i don't know 30 years or so maybe even a
little bit longer than that
conservatives have wanted to be the nice
sky party of saying no do whatever
you want do we're we're pro freedom
oh yeah you should totally shoot up
heroin and look at porn all the time
that's awesome yeah that's great
just don't make me pay for it just don't
hey yeah no it's totally cool
you can have like throuples and and do a
bunch of drugs and stuff
and like you know but and kick the bible
out of schools and kick prayer out of
schools and bring in drag queen story
hour that's awesome that's a blessing of
liberty
just don't make me pay for it huh you
know and you just think that's
not there's nothing conservative about
that it's not it's not coherent and and
i don't even think there's a
constituency for it
when you when you talk to young
conservatives
what they want is to be taken seriously
they want a orderly political
system and they want rules
okay and they don't it's really just the
kind of boomer con types
the the older conservatives of an older
generation who just say yeah do whatever
you want the true definition of liberty
is licentiousness and i think that
that's passing out of fashion right now
and you're seeing it throughout the
conservative movement
and yet the the boomer con types will
will decry this sort of thing
as a fascistic authoritarian this that
and the other thing
a good example is victor orban victor
orban is the excellent leader of hungary
he's done an excellent
excellent job as the later of hungary
one of the few
examples of a good politician in the in
the broader west
and he is regularly called a fascist and
a nazi and
authoritarian and this that and the
other thing and a bbc journalist
recently challenged him and said you do
not have
freedom of the press in hungary
and orban laughs at him he responds by
laughing he says are you
you're going to lecture me you here in
the anglosphere are going to lecture me
about freedom of the press
leftist activist of course they
criticize us but that's that's normal
come to hungary
see by your eyes and you can see how we
live and how is the press
if you go to the hungarian newsstand and
you ask for a paper
which attacking the government you will
get a dozen at least immediately so it's
free
what do you say to the opposition
parties the labour party here the
liberal democrat party here
who say you are the most regressive
leader in the european union they
they have concerns about remarks you
have made in the past
they say are anti-submit they say are
islamophobic
and that they say is just so
anti-immigration
what do you say in terms of
anti-immigration it could be
it could be true anti-summit is simply
ridiculous
we are more than fair and correct
country in that respect
we have a huge jewish community probably
the number three in uh
you repeatedly attack people like george
soros
with anti-semitic overtones oh no no
george
is a talented hungarian businessman very
strong rival
he is uh very much in favor of migration
financing and helping the ngos who are
doing that
we don't like it but it has nothing to
do with his ethnic identity you know
will you but you've criticized the
leading leftist financier of our age
you've criticized george soros and he's
a jew so that means that you're an
anti-semite
what are you talking about i've
criticized him because he spends
zillions of dollars trying to oust me
from office and open up the borders of
hungary has nothing to do
with his ethnicity has everything to do
with his political actions well you're
but you don't have freedom of the press
what are you talking about i've got a
dozen newspapers who attack me every
single day
but what about you bbc what about you
western anglo-sphere press
the bbc is attacking victor orban
because he is
following the will of his constituents
who want less immigration
the majority of americans want less
immigration too
poll after poll after poll shows this
not just illegal but legal immigration
and yet the american regime does not
permit that the american regime opens up
the borders
seems to me like hungary is much more
democratic than say the united states
what about the freedom of the press do
we have freedom of the press here in the
united states
to some degree we do but i don't think
very much the entire
mainstream press the major press is
dominated by the left
and and by leftist corporations actually
specifically
but then even let's say you've got a
conservative outlet like the new york
post and the new york post comes out
with a really
juicy story about hunter biden's laptop
and his business dealings and joe biden
during a presidential election and what
happens
it's not that the government's not that
the you know
the elected democrat president shuts
that down
at the time we had a republican
president it's that the regime shuts it
down it's that the big tech companies
shut it down it's that you can't even
message that story to somebody else
that's what happened with the new york
post
you couldn't even send that story
privately to somebody else
is that freedom of the press i don't
know you know before you accuse victor
orban take a look at yourself
before you accuse hungary of being
anti-democratic take a look
at liberal imperialism and say well is
this this is much more democratic i'm
not so sure
speaking of democratic integrity by the
way
there are some audits of votes going on
they're still auditing the 2020 votes
now
there's not a ton of news out on this
certainly not with the presidential
election but there is a little
story out of new hampshire there were
machine tabulated 2020 election results
in windham new hampshire
and it turns out that those results were
different
from a later hand recount and they're
saying this is because of the way the
ballots were folded and this that and
the other thing
and the democratic candidate
a democratic state house candidate
christie saint-laurent
lost her race and i just wanted a
recount
and so there was a recount it turns out
the democrat actually got more votes
than uh than ought to have been given
now they all the officials are saying
there's no evidence of fraud or
political bias
no evidence that this would have thrown
the race okay
i'm just pointing out here
the fraud generally speaking always
seems to go in one direction i'm not
saying without exception
there have been times that the recounts
and the accidental votes always seem to
go in one
one direction not saying all the time
there have been times when republicans
have gotten
votes that they shouldn't have to but
whenever we look into these things we we
seem to find some issues
and yet we're told that if we were in
any way to question
this around the country certainly with
regard to the presidential election
that would be a kooky crazy unacceptable
conspiracy theory that we're not even
allowed to post on the internet
because you see we have a free press we
have the first amendment and that's why
we're not allowed to talk about these
things right
pretty strange stuff makes you makes you
question
what sort of government we're really
living under are we living under the
constitution
are we living under this democratic
republic of ours
or are we living under some other system
a sort of liberal empire or a
secular progressive administrative state
what
what is the real nature of the
government well at times like this
you you can see the regime really expose
expose itself are we represented by the
american flag or are we represented by
the blm flag or the rainbow flag what
represents
the kind of system we're living under
today
speaking of nation states the who the
world health organization
has announced a new system for
describing coronavirus
the new system for naming covid and
covid variants
is getting rid of uh various nations
so you you know you're not allowed to
call it the china virus we haven't been
allowed to call it the china virus for a
long time or the kung flu or the wu flu
or lung power sicken or chop fluid
you're not allowed to do it don't you
dare
you're also not allowed to refer to the
indian variant now
now as i recall when there was a uk
variant floating around that was totally
fine
when it was a it was a western country
totally fine but when it was india or
china that's totally unacceptable so the
new
the new system this is going to make it
much easier they say
is uh according to the greek alphabet
alpha beta gamma pi these sorts of
things
and the who tweets quote today who has
announced a new naming system for coven
19 variants
the labels are based on the greek
alphabet making them simple
easy to say and remember it's so much
simpler instead of saying
indian variant to refer to the variant
that comes from india it's so much
simpler
to learn the greek alphabet and then
remember which greek letter corresponds
to which country isn't that easy and
simple
just makes it so much easier for you
but the re they actually acknowledge why
they did it the naming system aims to
prevent calling covet-19 variants by the
places where they're detected
which is stigmatizing and discriminatory
it's not not either of those things
and really what this is about is
obscuring the fact that china
caused this virus and very likely caused
it
in a laboratory and even possibly caused
it intentionally
that's what this is about obscur it's
not about
conveying truth it's about obscuring
truth i was i was just discussing this
in my upcoming books speechless
controlling words controlling my is
available now for pre-order
i was describing how did we get a bell
is there no
no no there we go okay uh oh oh oh no
oh no i pushed it one too far
uh are we gonna
[Music]
oh god i thought we'd only done done
four today okay well
they'll try to fix that camera uh
i was describing this difference between
euphemisms we all use euphemisms right
a euphemism is when you use soft words
to sugarcoat harsh realities
so a harsh reality for instance
is um that you know
a woman is aged let's say
you don't want to call a woman old how
dare you woman a lady never tells her
age so you say she's a woman of a
certain age
okay we all know what that means and
it's not a lie she really is a woman of
a certain age
and you don't want to call her an old
hag so okay makes perfect sense but
if you take another like a politically
correct euphemism and you say okay
instead of calling someone a criminal
we're going to call him a justice
involved person that's an actual
euphemism used
you're not just sort of softening what
you're saying about them
you're actually inverting the reality
because because whatever the criminal is
he's not involved with justice okay he's
actually involved with
injustice it's the opposite of what's
going on here
and that is what you're seeing that's
what you're seeing with all this kind of
orwellian talk
coming from the w.h.o and this is
all over the place this is even in
infected tennessee you know i love
tennessee i fled
los angeles gamora by the sea new
cellini's
fascistic i guess more communistic sort
of you know
wokest state didn't turn around i didn't
want to turn into a pillar of salt i
come to tennessee but this stuff's going
on in tennessee
tennessee is requiring all state
employees to complete an assignment on
diversity
and equity as part of their performance
reviews
this according to internal documents
from the tennessee department
of hr and this is what they write quote
although we're all affected by the
recent deaths of black americans black
employees are affected
disproportionately be considerate of
what employees are experiencing when
communicating with team members so we're
told
that certain deaths are worse than other
deaths in the united states and certain
people based on their skin color are
more sensitive and deserving of more
privileges than other people that's a
new
caste system okay that is a that is a
deeply unjust
sort of thing but it reminds us
that there's a big difference between
what we think that our government is and
what our government really is what we
think our law is
and what our law really is and i think
you're seeing this in conservatives
there's a group of conservatives that
seem to think that nothing has changed
since 1982
and they just want to keep their head in
the sand and go along with that and
there's another group of conservatives
who knows what time it is
and who knows that we need to change our
strategy or we're going to be
wiped out forever on the right and
uh that latter group of conservatives
are the ones who who seriously know
what's going on and if we want to fight
back at all we've got to recognize
that we've got to wake up and uh live in
the present if we want to reclaim the
glories of our national past
i'm michael also the michael show see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show dr anthony fauci's
emails emerge and they are not
particularly flattering plus president
biden unleashes a tirade against america
to commemorate the 100 year anniversary
of the tulsa massacre that's today on
the ben shapiro show give it a listen